From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. It is just so hot. That's my big thought. It is just so hot. And so, together, everybody. One, two, three. Everybody.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。天气真是太热了。这就是我目前最大的想法。真的是太热了。所以，大家一起来。一，二，三。大家。
One, two, three.
一，二，三。
[SCREAM]
[尖叫]
[SPLASH]
[落水声]
Ah, that's better. Here at the Holstein Park pool here on Chicago's West Side. Here in Chicago we've had some truly horrible days this summer, days where the air has had a kind of meaty thickness it is so humid. No wind off the lake. Thank you very much, Mr. Weather.
啊，舒服多了。这里是芝加哥西区的霍尔斯坦公园游泳池。今年夏天，芝加哥经历了一些极其糟糕的日子，空气中弥漫着一种潮湿的肉质厚重感。湖边没有风。非常感谢你，气象先生。
Torpor sets in. Torpor, actual torpor. After jumping into the swimming pool, Vanessa, Elizabeth, and Patrice do one bracing lap, and then spent, hang on the side inert for four hours. Next to the pool, the lifeguard that everybody is in love with, Adrian, lays on his side among a group of intensely captivated 12 and 13 year old girls, plus a few little boys. Not one of them can move.
昏睡感袭来。一种迟钝，真正的迟钝。在跳进游泳池后，凡妮莎、伊丽莎白和帕特里斯游了一个振奋人心的来回，然后就精疲力竭地挂在池边，一动不动地待了四个小时。在泳池边，大家都爱慕的救生员阿德里安侧躺在一群极其着迷的12、13岁女孩以及几个小男孩中间。他们中没有一个人能动弹。
Sing that one song, a kid asks.
唱那首歌吧，一个孩子请求道。
Nah, [SPEAKING SPANISH] my Mexican song?
不，[西班牙语交谈]我的墨西哥歌曲？
Yeah, sing it.
对，唱吧。
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
[用西班牙语唱歌]
Adrian looks up at the group.
阿德里安抬头看着这群人。
See, what? Armondo, are you falling asleep? I'm lullabying you to sleep?
看，怎么了？阿蒙多，你快睡着了吗？我在给你唱摇篮曲吗？
For real, man.
真的，伙计。
Who can blame Armondo? Who, for that matter, can get up the energy to give a damn in this heat? Today on our program, what to do in the hottest heat of summer when you're not sleeping right and simply walking to the car or the bus takes it all out of you. And you know that you're not thinking straight and there is not a thing that you can do about it. We know what you did this summer. Our program today in three acts.
谁能责怪阿蒙多呢？再说，在这种高温下，谁又有精力去在乎什么呢？今天我们的节目主题是，当你在夏日最炎热的时候睡眠不足，连走到车边或公交站都耗尽体力时，该做些什么。你知道自己无法冷静思考，也无能为力。我们知道你这个夏天做了什么。今天的节目分为三个部分。
Act One, Just Three Thousand More Miles to the Beach. In that act, Scott Carrier on a road trip. No air conditioning. Too hot to stay in the car, too hot to get out of the car.
第一幕，离海滩还有三千英里。在这一幕中，斯科特·卡里尔进行了一次公路旅行。没有空调。待在车里太热，离开车也太热。
Act Two, It's Not the Heat, It's the Humility, in which we move into an environment that is so fantastically, oppressively hot that the people there have convinced themselves that sweating-- sweating by itself-- is actually getting something done.
第二幕，不是热的问题，是谦卑的问题，我们要进入一个极其、压抑地炎热的环境，那里的人们已经说服自己，出汗——仅仅是出汗——实际上是在完成某项工作。
Act Three, You Can Have Your Cave and Eat It Too. Sarah Vowell brings us the story of a national dispute involving a cave, a sandwich, park rangers, scientists, and, yes, always good for a laugh, the world famous United States Congress. Stay with us.
第三幕，你可以拥有你的洞穴并享受它。莎拉·沃威尔为我们带来了一个关于国家争端的故事，涉及一个洞穴、一个三明治、公园管理员、科学家，当然，还有永远能引人发笑的、世界闻名的美国国会。请继续收听。
Act One, Just Three Thousand Miles to the Beach. Like so many summer stories, this one from Scott Carrier, starts with a whim and ends with a whimper.
第一幕，离海滩还有三千英里。像许多夏日故事一样，这个来自斯科特·卡里尔的故事，始于一时兴起，终结于呜咽。
It was summer, the middle of a hot summer. I drove to San Francisco to visit a friend and escape the heat, but when I got there, almost right as I got off the Bay Bridge, my truck began to die. It lost its power, and I could barely make it up the steep hills. I was stalling traffic, throwing out big, black clouds of smoke, forcing people to cover their faces and walk on the other side of the street.
那是夏天，一个炎热夏天的中间。我开车去旧金山探望一个朋友并躲避酷暑，但当我到达那里，几乎就在我刚下海湾大桥时，我的卡车就开始不行了。它失去了动力，我几乎无法爬上陡峭的山坡。我挡住了交通，喷出大团黑烟，迫使路人遮住脸走到街的另一边。
It had never been a good truck, always a collector of bad luck-- dents, cracked cylinder block, broken clutch push rod, broken brake lines, and smashed head lights. All sad stories.
这辆卡车从来都不好，一直是个倒霉蛋的收藏品——凹痕、气缸体开裂、离合器推杆断裂、刹车管破裂、大灯粉碎。全是悲伤的故事。
I considered driving it to Fisherman's Wharf, taking the plates, ceremoniously shooting the horse, and walking away from it. But then, I slept on it, and in the morning I thought, maybe a mechanic can fix it, someone who actually knows about engines.
我曾考虑把它开到渔人码头，卸下车牌，举行个仪式把这匹“马”射杀，然后弃它而去。但后来，我睡了一觉，早晨我想，也许机械师能修好它，一个真正懂发动机的人。
I pulled into a Quick Tune, and a guy there put it on the scope. His name was Chien from Vietnam. He didn't speak a lot of English.
我开进了一家快速调校店，那里的一个家伙把它放在检测仪上。他叫钱，来自越南。他英语说得不多。
[SPEAKING VIETNAMESE]
[越南语交谈]
He said my EGR valve was working too hard, putting too much oxygen or not enough oxygen into the combustion chamber, but that he'd fixed it by plugging a vacuum hose with a spark plug he'd pulled out of the garbage.
他说我的废气再循环阀工作太过度了，导致燃烧室内的氧气过多或过少，但他通过用一个从垃圾桶里翻出来的火花塞堵住真空管解决了这个问题。
The car more power. Right now more power, OK?
车现在动力更足了。现在动力更足，好吗？
Now, he said, the car had power. And he was right. The car did have power. I got on Interstate 80 headed toward Sacramento doing 85 miles an hour going back home to Salt Lake City.
现在，他说，车有动力了。他是对的。车确实有了动力。我开上80号州际公路前往萨克拉门托，以每小时85英里的速度回盐湖城的家。
But then in Sacramento, I saw a sign that said US Highway 50, Ocean City, Maryland, 3,073 miles, and I took the exit. 3,000 miles. Not that far.
但在萨克拉门托，我看到一个牌子写着50号美国国道，马里兰州大洋城，3073英里，我就拐了出去。3000英里。不算太远。
I knew there was a strong possibility that the spark plug in the vacuum line was only a temporary fix and that the engine might lose its power at any moment, and I'd have to walk away from it. But it was summer-- the middle of a hot summer-- and I didn't have anything better to do.
我知道火花塞堵在真空管里很可能只是个临时修复，引擎随时可能失去动力，我可能不得不放弃它。但那是夏天——一个炎热夏天的中间——我没有更好的事情可做。
Highway 50, where it runs across the Basin and Range, is known as the loneliest road in America. It's an old route, probably ancient, first used by white men in 1849 on their way to Sutter's Mill, then the Pony Express and the Overland Stage in the early 1860s. Mark Twain rode the Overland Stage in 1861, and he hated this particular stretch across the Basin and Range. He said it was worse than the horrors of the Sahara.
50号公路穿过盆地和山脉，被称为美国最孤独的公路。这是一条古老的路线，可能很古老，1849年白人前往萨特磨坊时首次使用，后来是19世纪60年代初的驿马快信和陆路驿站。马克·吐温曾在1861年乘坐过陆路驿站的马车，他讨厌这段穿越盆地和山脉的路。他说这里比撒哈拉沙漠的恐怖还要糟糕。
That's one reason it's so lonely out here. The other is that almost all traffic to the coast now follows Interstate 80 to the north or Interstate 15 to the south leaving this huge open space containing 100 separate mountain ranges and 150 separate basins, sort of like the surface of a golf ball.
这是它如此孤独的原因之一。另一个原因是，现在几乎所有通往海岸的交通都沿着北边的80号州际公路或南边的15号州际公路，留下了这片巨大的空旷空间，其中包含100个独立的山脉和150个盆地，有点像高尔夫球的表面。
On a clear day, on this part of Highway 50, it's easy to see 50 miles in every direction, sometimes 100. But it was a summer of forest fires, seven million acres burning throughout the inner mountain west, all caused by dry, violent thunderstorms that blew through in June leaving smoke in their wake. Then it got hot and windy, and every day just got smokier and smokier to where in the morning and evening you could stare straight at the sun, to where it was like you were living through the final days of a dying planet.
在晴天，在50号公路的这一段，很容易看到每个方向50英里，有时是100英里。但那是一个森林大火的夏天，内山地西部的700万英亩土地正在燃烧，全部是由6月份呼啸而过的干燥、狂暴的雷暴引起的，留下了滚滚浓烟。然后天气变得炎热多风，每一天都变得越来越烟雾缭绕，以至于在早晨和傍晚你可以直视太阳，感觉就像你正在经历一个垂死星球的最后日子。
From the desert of the Basin and Range, Highway 50 enters the desert of the Colorado Plateau through sandstone canyons, like from the Planet of the Apes, across the Green and Colorado rivers and then following the Gunnison River up the Western Slope of the Rockies to Monarch Pass, crossing the Continental Divide at 11,000 feet.
从盆地和山脉的沙漠，50号公路穿过砂岩峡谷进入科罗拉多高原的沙漠，就像在《人猿星球》里一样，穿过绿河和科罗拉多河，然后沿着甘尼森河向上到达落基山西坡的君主山口，在11000英尺处穿过大陆分水岭。
My truck ran with the check engine soon light blinking on and off, gasping and coughing its way over the pass. But it made it up and over, and from there it was downhill for 100 miles along the Arkansas River-- people in kayaks running the rapids-- to the town of Pueblo on the Eastern Slope of the Rockies looking out at the Great Plains.
我的卡车闪烁着检查引擎灯，气喘吁吁、咳嗽着翻过山口。但它还是上去了，从那里开始，沿着阿肯色河下坡100英里——人们在皮划艇里穿过急流——到达落基山东坡的小镇普韦布洛，眺望大平原。
I stopped there to see a friend, Albert [? Pichak ?]. We ended up in his backyard where he showed me his rock collection.
我在那儿停下来看望一个朋友，阿尔伯特·皮查克。我们最后去了他的后院，他向我展示了他的岩石收藏。
Here's some rainbow obsidian, really beautiful stuff. I'll strike a little chunk off if I can find my sandstone. OK. It's not safe to do this without some sort of protection, because it's very sharp and you can get cut. See. You can see the color. It's really a beautiful stone.
这是彩虹黑曜石，非常漂亮的东西。如果我能找到我的砂岩，我可以敲下一小块。好了。没有某种保护措施做这个是不安全的，因为它非常锋利，你会被割伤。看。你能看到颜色。它确实是一块漂亮的石头。
It's a black rock, but at a certain angle to the sun it reflects-- what colors do you see there?
它是一块黑色的石头，但在太阳的特定角度下，它会反射——你看到了什么颜色？
Green, blue, purple. Here we go. Is that amazing or what? When I first started flinting that thing, I thought that obsidian came in black and black, you know. It's amazing the colors that you can see.
绿色、蓝色、紫色。来吧。这太神奇了，不是吗？当我刚开始敲打那个东西时，我以为黑曜石只有黑色和黑色，你知道的。你能看到的颜色真是太令人惊讶了。
I find that it's like a meditative state working with the stone. It gives me a sense that there's more to everything around us than just-- more to stone than just being an inanimate object, that actually there is energy with it, that when you make something, that energy is transferred to it.
我发现处理这种石头就像一种冥想状态。它让我觉得我们周围的一切不仅仅是——石头不仅仅是一个无生命的物体，实际上它有能量，当你制造出某样东西时，那种能量就会转移到它身上。
Albert made me a five inch Clovis spear point, black obsidian that reflected tiny rainbows in each chip and groove, sharp as a razor. I put it on my dashboard hoping its energy would somehow transfer to my engine.
阿尔伯特为我做了一个五英寸长的克洛维斯矛头，黑色的黑曜石在每个缺口和凹槽中反射出微小的彩虹，锋利如剃刀。我把它放在仪表板上，希望它的能量能以某种方式转移到我的引擎上。
From the Rocky Mountains, Highway 50 runs across the High Plains in sort of a connect-the-dots between small farming and ranching towns, mainly Hispanic, a landscape once famous for buffalo but is now famous for cantaloupe. Leaving Pueblo, the weather was partly cloudy, 90 degrees, and low humidity, but it became hotter and more humid with every mile to where in central Kansas it was over 105 and very humid, no clouds, a little wind. And it had been like that for a long time, several weeks anyway. The fields of corn, six and seven feet tall, had turned brown. The stocks and the husks around the cobs were dry as a bone.
从落基山脉出发，50号公路穿过高平原，在小型农耕和牧场城镇之间连接，主要是西班牙裔，这里曾经以野牛闻名，现在以哈密瓜闻名。离开普韦布洛时，天气多云，90华氏度，湿度低，但每一英里都变得更热、更潮湿，以至于在堪萨斯州中部，气温超过了105度，而且非常潮湿，没有云，有一点风。这种情况已经持续了很长时间，至少几周了。玉米地长到六七英尺高，已经变成了褐色。玉米棒周围的茎和皮干得像骨头一样。
To deal with the heat, I poured water on my clothes and drove with the windows down, and I sought refuge in Walmarts on the edges of the small towns. Every town had one, although some towns had Walmart supercenters, a disaster for Main Street, but they were like oases to me. I'd go in and get hit by a wave of cold air that was like jumping into a mountain lake. It took my breath away.
为了应付炎热，我把水泼在衣服上，摇下车窗开车，我还在小镇边缘的沃尔玛寻求庇护。每个镇都有一个，尽管有些镇有沃尔玛购物广场，这对大街来说是一场灾难，但它们对我来说就像绿洲。我走进去，被一股冷空气击中，就像跳进了一个高山湖泊。它让我喘不过气来。
I'd take a cart and walk through the aisles selecting items like a sleeping bag, a fishing rod, 100 feet of rope, spray paint, watercolors, a six-quart cooler, power drill, clock radio. And then, when the cart was full, I'd backtrack, returning everything to its place on the shelf. If I concentrated and thought carefully about my selections, the whole process would take a couple of hours. Then I'd get back on the road and drive through the sweltering heat.
我会推着购物车在过道里走，挑选睡袋、鱼竿、100英尺绳子、喷漆、水彩画、6夸脱冷藏箱、电钻、时钟收音机等物品。然后，当购物车满时，我会往回走，把所有东西放回货架上的原位。如果我集中精力并仔细考虑我的选择，整个过程需要几个小时。然后我会回到路上，穿过酷暑继续开车。
My truck, surprisingly, ran without overheating, but I was so hot, I went brain dead. At one point, I found myself off the highway driving along a back road going east, but I couldn't remember how I'd gotten off the highway. I came to a small town, and there were some cars parked in front of a bar. The sign at the bank across the street said it was 106 degrees.
令人惊讶的是，我的卡车没有过热，但我太热了，大脑死机了。有一次，我发现自己偏离了高速公路，沿着一条向东的乡村公路行驶，但我记不起自己是怎么从高速公路上拐下来的。我来到一个小镇，酒吧前停着几辆车。街对面的银行牌子上显示是106度。
I'm Sam Kennedy, and I live up around Big Springs, and we're in Overbrook, Kansas right now.
我是萨姆·肯尼迪，我住在比格斯普林斯附近，我们现在在堪萨斯州的奥弗布鲁克。
I'm Crystal Kennedy. I believe this is our 16th day of over 100 degrees. We haven't had weather like this, they say, since 1936.
我是克里斯托·肯尼迪。我相信这是我们第16天超过100度了。他们说自1936年以来我们就没有过这样的天气。
We're getting pretty well burnt up now, pretty dry. I've got beans that are probably five foot high and they're probably the size  of buckshot right now because they've all burnt.
我们现在被烧得够呛，非常干。我的豆子可能有五英尺高，现在大概只有铅弹那么大，因为它们全都烧焦了。
And the chickens are panting. They stick their little slitted tongues out and huff and puff. And my bees, they were just all over the hive last night, and they're trying to keep everything cool in there for the queen. But I'm going to harvest probably this next weekend. I'm going to take the honey and start feeding them, because there's no plants here for them to live on. Everything's dried up.
鸡在喘气。它们伸出细细的舌头喘着粗气。我的蜜蜂，它们昨晚就在蜂箱上，试图在里面保持凉爽，为了蜂王。但我大概会在下个周末收获。我会取走蜂蜜，开始喂养它们，因为这里没有植物供它们生存了。一切都枯萎了。
And here we buy all this seed, buy all this fertilizer, buy all this spray to keep everything nice and weed free, and at the end of the year, you take the crops to the elevator and you sell them, and you get this check, and it looks like a really big check. But then when you take it to the bank, a lot of times you'll just barely break even. You might have $50 left.
我们在这里买种子，买化肥，买喷雾来保持一切整洁无杂草，到年底，你把作物送到粮仓卖掉，你拿到这张支票，看起来是一张很大额的支票。但当你把它带到银行时，很多时候你只是勉强收支平衡。你可能只剩下50美元。
So that's when you come over here to this place and drink a few beers and talk to your friends. And they're all in the same shape. Everybody's been the same.
所以这就是你来到这个地方喝几杯啤酒和朋友聊天的时候。他们都处于同样的境地。每个人都一样。
I saw two cars spontaneously combust in Kansas. They got so hot, they lit on fire and burned, spewing black, toxic smoke from under the hoods. One was in a parking garage in Lawrence near the Natural History Museum on the university campus. The other car exploded on the freeway around Kansas City, two teenage boys in an old Mustang.
我在堪萨斯州看到两辆车自燃了。它们太热了，以至于起火烧毁，从引擎盖下喷出有毒的黑烟。一辆是在劳伦斯大学校园自然历史博物馆附近的停车场。另一辆车在堪萨斯城附近的公路上爆炸，那是两个十几岁的男孩开着一辆旧野马。
East of Kansas City once over the Missouri River, Highway 50 winds through the hills and forests of the Bible Belt, the Ozarks. Dead turtles upside down and bloating on the side of the road, live rattlesnakes in the churches, bugs frying in the blue light zappers of Sedalia. Churches with signs out front saying, dusty bibles lead to dirty lives. Free trip to heaven. Details inside. And the crickets or locusts or whatever they were was like a jungle.
堪萨斯城以东，越过密苏里河后，50号公路蜿蜒穿过圣经带的丘陵和森林，欧扎克地区。路边死乌龟倒扣着膨胀，教堂里有活的响尾蛇，塞达利亚的蓝光灭虫器里炸焦的虫子。教堂门前的标牌写着：尘封的圣经导致肮脏的生活。免费去天堂。详情在里面。蟋蟀、蝗虫什么的，吵得像丛林一样。
I stopped in Jefferson City at midnight. The streets were vacant and smelled from the mud of the Missouri River running just north of the capitol building. I tried to go down to the river to sleep, but there was no way to get to it from the city. I ran into fences and thick forests, and so I drove on, stopping at a convenience store to buy three beers which I proceeded to pound back while cruising through a fog.
我在午夜时分在杰斐逊城停下来。街道空荡荡的，散发着州议会大厦北边密苏里河泥浆的味道。我试图走到河边睡觉，但从城里根本过不去。我撞上了栅栏和茂密的森林，所以我继续开车，在一家便利店停下买了三瓶啤酒，然后在雾中行驶时把它们喝干了。
I beg you, my children, as your mother, your mother's mother, who cries tears of sorrow upon you all, please remember this. The time is growing short. I have wandered throughout earth trying to warn you, my children, depending on a small handful of moral souls to bring these messages to you.
我的孩子们，我恳求你们，作为你们的母亲，你们母亲的母亲，在你们所有人身上流下悲伤的泪水，请记住这一点。时间不多了。我游历了大地，试图警告你们，我的孩子们，依赖少数几个有道德的灵魂将这些信息带给你们。
But what does he really have? Nothing, because when he wakes up after death, he wakes up in hell. On the other hand, here's the poor man, Lazarus, who has none of the needs, the physical needs satisfied. He lives out of the garbage pail. The dogs lick his sores. And it looks like the Lord just has forgotten him, absolutely forgotten him.
但他到底有什么？什么都没有，因为当他在死后醒来时，他在地狱里醒来。另一方面，这是穷人拉撒路，他没有任何需求，生理需求得到满足。他靠垃圾桶生活。狗舔着他的伤口。看起来上帝似乎忘记了他，绝对忘记了他。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语交谈]
--unto them, because it is given unto you to know the mysteries--
……给你们，因为赋予你们认识奥秘的权力——
You know that says. I can't quote the whole thing, but you know what that says. A lot of people-- Oh, I don't understand. It's [UNINTELLIGIBLE] so hard, that it [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] has always had it hard before they came to Christ like myself and others. I understand the example you were giving a few sentences ago about Ethiopia and so forth and so on. I can relate to that. I'm black. I can relate to that. I mean--
你知道那是怎么说的。我不能引用全部，但你知道那是什么意思。很多人——哦，我不明白。这太难了，以至于在他们信奉基督之前，像我这样的其他人总是觉得很困难。我明白你刚才提到的关于埃塞俄比亚等等的例子。我能理解。我是黑人。我能理解。我的意思是——
East of St. Louis after the Arch and the Mississippi River, Highway 50 gets crowded. What was once the loneliest road in America becomes America's Main Street, or that's what I read they call it, and it's appropriate. Some people might think it quaint to drive through the downtowns of one small town after another, but I was hating it. There was a lot of traffic, a lot of cops, used car lots, strip malls.
圣路易斯以东，越过拱门和密西西比河后，50号公路变得拥挤。曾经美国最孤独的公路变成了美国的“大街”，或者我读到他们这么叫它，这很贴切。有些人可能会觉得开车穿过一个小镇又一个小镇的市中心很古雅，但我讨厌它。车流量很大，警察很多，二手车行，带状购物中心。
Sometimes the highway was a four lane freeway. Sometimes it was a neighborhood street running by driveways and front lawns and big houses. Sometimes it vanished altogether, and I'd find myself on some other road with a different name.
有时高速公路是四车道高速。有时它是穿过车道、前草坪和大房子的社区街道。有时它完全消失了，我发现自己在另一条名字不同的路上。
And my engine was running like the timing belt had lost its shape, running lean and then running rich. It was giving up, wanting to die, but I pushed it mercilessly scared of being stranded in middle America. I drove and drove, and it was like I wasn't getting anywhere. I drove without sleeping. It was too warm and sticky to sleep.
我的引擎跑起来就像正时皮带失去了形状，运行得很稀，然后又运行得很浓。它正在放弃，想要死掉，但我毫不留情地推动它，害怕被困在中美洲。我开车，开车，就像我哪儿也没去一样。我开车不睡觉。天气太暖和粘稠了，睡不着。
Somewhere in Ohio I stopped to talk to a guy who was sitting by the side of the road whittling walking sticks.
在俄亥俄州的某个地方，我停下来和一个坐在路边削手杖的家伙聊天。
All of these are my sticks. This is apple wood, and this is sourwood. I bought 300 off my brother in '94 and 300 in '97. I've bought 780 sticks off of him for the last four years. I've got all different kinds of wood, just about. About any kind of wood you name, I've got it. I've got oak [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
这些都是我的手杖。这是苹果木，这是酸木。我在94年从我兄弟那买了300根，97年买了300根。过去四年我从他那买了780根手杖。我几乎有各种各样的木头。你能说出名字的任何一种木头，我都有。我有橡木……
I've got them all initialed. I've got the year I've cut them. And I've got my initial on them. I've got a K on them and I've got them all dated. Now I've bought some that's got carved on. I don't do no carving. I'm a whittler. I call myself a whittler. I'm not a carver. I've bought some that's got carved on, but I don't put my initial on them. I don't date them.
我都在上面刻了首字母。我有我切割它们的年份。我还在上面刻了我的首字母。我在上面刻了个K，我还给它们都标了日期。现在我买了一些有雕刻的。我不会雕刻。我是削木头的。我叫自己削木头的。我不是雕刻家。我买过一些有雕刻的，但我不给它们刻首字母。我不给它们标注日期。
Why do you call yourself a whittler instead of a carver?
为什么你称自己为削木头的而不是雕刻家？
Well, because I don't carve faces. I mean, I'm trying to get my son started doing the carving, you see. It makes a stick sell better. But I enjoy doing this. I've been doing it 13 years, so I must have-- I did this eight years. I didn't sell many sticks at all, but the last five years I'm well satisfied with what I'm doing.
嗯，因为我不雕刻人脸。我的意思是，我正在尝试让我儿子开始做雕刻，你知道。这能让手杖卖得更好。但我喜欢做这个。我做了13年了，所以我想——我做了8年。我没卖掉多少手杖，但过去5年我对自己在做的事情很满意。
What made the difference in the sales? For the first eight years you didn't sell very much and then what happened?
是什么导致了销量的变化？前8年你没卖出多少，后来发生了什么？
Well, the news got out what I do and everybody-- the public is funny. You'd be surprised how people is. I'm not trying to get rich. I've got $5 sticks there. I've got $12 in them. I bought three sticks and I sell them three sticks for $10. I spend anywhere from-- well, most usually I'm out here eight o'clock in the morning until eight at night. I sit here and whittle. I enjoy it, really, really.
嗯，新闻传开了我在做什么，每个人——公众很奇怪。你会惊讶人们是怎么样的。我不是想发财。我有5美元的手杖。我花了12美元。我买三根，我三根卖10美元。我花的时间从——嗯，通常我从早上8点一直到晚上8点都在这儿。我坐在这儿削木头。我真的很享受，真的，真的。
I woke up in a parking lot next to the Ohio River at Clarksburg, West Virginia, a quiet morning. The word Ohio comes from an Iroquois word meaning beautiful river, and it was, big and sleepy.
我在西弗吉尼亚州克拉克斯堡的俄亥俄河边的一个停车场醒来，一个安静的早晨。“俄亥俄”这个词来自易洛魁语，意思是美丽的河流，确实如此，又大又安静。
You grew up here.
你在这里长大。
I grew up here. I love it. That's all I need.
我在这里长大。我爱它。这就是我所需要的一切。
I was reading in a book that the word Ohio comes from an Indian word, meaning beautiful river. Is that right or is that--
我在一本书里读到，俄亥俄这个词来自一个印第安词，意思是美丽的河流。那是真的吗，还是——
That's probably true, because there's a lot of history of Indians up through the whole Mid-Ohio Valley here. There's Indian mounds that go up further north and there's history that goes down south. My grandmother herself was an Indian. If you was to go into the corn fields after the farmers plow, you can actually find arrowheads, perfectly preserved arrowheads that the Indians made.
那可能是真的，因为整个俄亥俄河谷中游都有很多印第安人的历史。北边有印第安土墩，南边也有历史。我的祖母本人就是一位印第安人。如果你在农民耕地后进入玉米地，你实际上可以找到箭头，完美保存的印第安人制造的箭头。
So what tribe-- what tribes are from around here and what tribe are you descended from?
那么什么部落——这里周围有哪些部落，你是哪个部落的后裔？
I don't know what tribe. My father's deceased, but he had mentioned several times and I don't know actually what tribe. I didn't even know my grandmother. She was already passed away by the time I was born. But I know there's definitely history. I would love to do-- I didn't even know a whole lot about my father, and I wish I knew more about that, too.
我不知道是什么部落。我父亲已经去世了，但他提到过几次，我实际上不知道是什么部落。我甚至不认识我的祖母。在我出生时她已经去世了。但我知道这里肯定有历史。我很想做——我甚至对我父亲了解不多，我也希望我能更多地了解那些事。
From the Ohio River, Highway 50 crosses the Monongahela Valley and then begins winding up through the Allegheny Mountains, following a route originally surveyed by 16-year-old George Washington in 1748. He was a friend and employee of Lord Fairfax who used to own this land.
从俄亥俄河出发，50号公路穿过莫农加希拉河谷，然后开始蜿蜒穿过阿勒格尼山脉，沿着1748年16岁的乔治·华盛顿最初勘测的路线。他是费尔法克斯勋爵的朋友和雇员，费尔法克斯勋爵曾经拥有这片土地。
Washington ended up with 30,000 acres from the Potomac to the Ohio, and when he became president, he authorized funding for the construction of what was then called the Northwest Turnpike, which is how Highway 50 began, a route to the Ohio and the wilderness beyond.
华盛顿最终获得了从波托马克河到俄亥俄河的3万英亩土地，当他成为总统时，他批准了资助建设当时被称为西北收费公路的工程，这就是50号公路的开端，一条通往俄亥俄和更远荒野的路线。
Crossing the Alleghenies was more difficult than going over the Rockies. The road is narrow and winding with a lot of up and down, thick forests, crossing a number of passes, and a lot of logging trucks and coal trucks. And then my truck was just pitiful. I'd be going 40 miles an hour, and there'd be a big truck right on my tail trying to get around.
穿过阿勒格尼山脉比翻越落基山脉更困难。道路狭窄蜿蜒，起伏很大，森林茂密，跨越多个山口，还有很多运木卡车和运煤卡车。然后我的卡车简直太可怜了。我以每小时40英里的速度行驶，后面紧跟着一辆大卡车想超车。
In the small town of Mount Storm at the summit of what seemed like the highest mountain, I stopped to take a break and let a coal truck go by and watched an old man mowing his lawn.
在似乎是最高山峰顶端的蒙特斯托姆小镇，我停下来休息，让一辆运煤卡车经过，看着一位老人割草。
That's a Chief, Lawn Chief, True Value Lawn Chief. That's sold by several local hardware stores in this area. I've owned it for two years. I start on my outer edge of my property and I make circles inward. I like to throw my grass one direction all the time-- same direction-- so that I don't mow the same grass over and over. Some people like to mow it over and over. That's called mulching. I don't care much for that. I killed a small snake over in that area a while ago. I ran over him with that.
那是Chief牌，Lawn Chief，True Value Lawn Chief。这个地区几家当地五金店都有卖。我拥有它两年了。我从我财产的最外缘开始，向内做圆圈。我喜欢总是把草往一个方向抛——同一个方向——这样我就不会反复割同样的草。有些人喜欢反复割它。那叫覆盖。我不怎么喜欢那样。刚才我在那个区域弄死了一条小蛇。我用它压过了他。
You saw it go under or you heard it get chopped?
你看到他钻到下面，还是听到他被砍断了？
I saw him go under.
我看到他钻到下面去了。
I drove into Washington, DC in the morning and spent the day walking around the Smithsonian Mall, visiting Kenneth Snelson's tensegrity needle outside the Hirshhorn. And then, I drove out of the city at night over the Chesapeake Bay Bridge-- all lit up and beautiful-- to Ocean City, Maryland. Highway 50 ends there at the boardwalk along the beach, 3,200 miles from the Pacific at San Francisco.
我在早晨开车进入华盛顿特区，花了一天时间在史密森尼博物馆大厦周围闲逛，参观了赫什霍恩博物馆外的肯尼斯·斯内尔森的张拉整体针。然后，我在晚上开车离开城市，越过切萨皮克湾大桥——灯火通明，美丽动人——前往马里兰州大洋城。50号公路在那里结束，就在海滩边的木板路上，距离太平洋旧金山有3200英里。
I slept in my cab. In the morning I watched a guy building a giant head of Jesus out of sand on the beach, and then I went swimming. It was the first time I'd cooled off in days.
我睡在车厢里。早上我看着一个家伙在沙滩上用沙子堆起一个巨大的耶稣头，然后我去游泳了。这是我几天来第一次凉快下来。
And then, my truck died. It spewed out a big, black cloud of exhaust and gave up the ghost. It was over. I pulled the plates, stuffed my things in a bag, took the stereo and my rainbow obsidian spear point, and left the key in the ignition. It was evening, raining hard, but I was only 2,300 miles from home.
然后，我的卡车死火了。它喷出一大团黑烟，彻底完蛋了。一切都结束了。我拔下车牌，把我的东西塞进袋子里，带走音响和彩虹黑曜石矛头，把钥匙留在点火开关里。那是傍晚，雨下得很大，但我距离家只有2300英里。
Scott Carrier lives in Salt Lake City. Coming up, what the park service has against crumbs, and a place that's so hot and humid even the crumbs get sweaty. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
斯科特·卡里尔住在盐湖城。接下来，公园管理局为什么反对面包屑，以及一个即使是面包屑也会出汗的炎热潮湿的地方。我们的节目继续，来自国际公共广播电台，稍后回来。
[MUSIC - "SUMMER IN THE CITY" BY BARRY MORROW]
[音乐 - 巴里·莫罗的“城市之夏”]
This is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, We Know What You Did This Summer, stories of mind-altering, body-stopping, torpor-inducing heat.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种不同类型的故事。今天的节目，“我们知道你这个夏天做了什么”，关于令人头脑发昏、身体停止运转、诱发迟钝的炎热的故事。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, It's Not the Heat, It Is the Humility. During the hottest days of August here in Chicago, Jonathan Goldstein sought out an environment that was yet hotter. It was not hot enough. He sought out yet hotter, and he found a place, the Division Street Russian Bath. The place is so hot and humid that literally our equipment does not work there-- tape recorders cannot function-- so Jonathan is here to tell the story.
我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，不是热的问题，是谦卑的问题。在芝加哥八月最炎热的日子里，乔纳森·戈尔茨坦寻找了一个更热的环境。这还不够热。他寻找了更热的地方，他找到了一个地方，分部街俄罗斯浴室。这个地方太热、太潮湿，以至于我们的设备在那里根本无法使用——录音机无法运行——所以乔纳森在这里讲述这个故事。
Jimmy Colucci is sitting bare-chested behind his desk wrapped only in a tiny wet sheet, and there's something about it that says there's a better way to live, a way that's more brazen, more comfortable, and quite frankly, more naked.
吉米·科鲁奇赤裸上身坐在办公桌后，只裹着一块小湿床单，这说明有一种更好的生活方式，一种更厚颜无耻、更舒适、坦率地说，更裸露的方式。
Jimmy's the owner of the Division Street Bath, and his office is right upstairs of the steam. He's just come up from his daily sweat, and sitting there at his desk dressed only in a sheet, he looks like the guy who does paperwork for the Pharaoh.
吉米是分部街浴室的老板，他的办公室就在蒸汽房楼上。他刚从每日的汗蒸中出来，坐在桌子前只披着一块床单，看起来就像法老的文书官。
When I ask him what makes the heat at his bathhouse so special, he tells me that he provides a heat that's different than anything else offered around the country. If blindfolded, would he be able to tell his heat from other heat? Absolutely, he says. But what about the other kind of heat you hear so much about, I ask. The kind that's claustrophobic and unbearable, the kind that causes the elderly to drop like flies and the young to scream at their boyfriends just because they got them the wrong kind of sandwich. I don't make that kind of heat, Jimmy answers.
当我问他是什么让他的浴室里的热度如此特别时，他告诉我他提供了一种不同于全国各地其他任何地方的热度。如果蒙住眼睛，他能分辨出他的热度和其他热度吗？绝对能，他说。但我问他，那种你常听说的热度呢？那种令人幽闭恐惧、无法忍受的热度，那种导致老年人像苍蝇一样倒下，年轻人因为给他们买了错误的三明治而对男朋友尖叫的热度。我不制造那种热度，吉米回答。
To better understand the power of this heat, Jimmy sends me down into the steam with a towel, a sheet, and a bar of soap. First I shower, the wet sheet around my waist feeling so wrong yet so right. I ask myself, how does one comport oneself clothed only in a sheet? Like a stoic Roman senator? A caught lothario shimmying down a boudoir drainpipe? I decide to clinch one hand around the tied knot and play a situation comedy guy locked out of the house wrapped in a welcome mat.
为了更好地理解这种热度的力量，吉米让我带上一条毛巾、一块床单和一块肥皂下到蒸汽房。我先洗了个澡，围在腰间的湿床单感觉既不对劲又恰到好处。我问自己，一个人怎么能只披着床单举止得体呢？像一个坚忍的罗马参议员？像一个被抓到的、溜进闺房排水管的私通者？我决定一只手紧紧抓住系着的结，扮演一个被锁在门外、裹着欢迎门垫的处境喜剧角色。
The place has the all business utilitarian look of a boiler room, cracked concrete tiles and mildewy wood. And then Jake appears. He is a small Jewish man from the old country. He is naked except for his flip flops, gold chain, and sun hat, which he keeps drenched in water. Last week, I ate a big thing of spinach, Jake informs me by way of introduction. I ate like a pig. It gave me diarrhea for two weeks, then they gave me something for that, and now I'm constipated. He pauses a beat to allow the irony to be absorbed.
这个地方有锅炉房的那种实用主义外观，破裂的混凝土瓷砖和发霉的木头。然后杰克出现了。他是一个来自老家的矮个子犹太人。除了人字拖、金链子和一直浸着水的遮阳帽外，他一丝不挂。上周，我吃了一大堆菠菜，杰克作为开场白告诉我。我像猪一样吃。这让我拉了两周肚子，然后他们给了我治那个的东西，现在我便秘了。他停顿了一拍，让这种讽刺被吸收。
When he's not in the bathhouse, Jake wears two hearing aids. Without them he can't hear a thing, so he talks, and I listen. Over the sound of the shower and the echoing voices, I only catch bits. As we talk, Jake moves closer and closer, and as he does, I slowly, unconsciously inch backwards until finally I'm in a corner under a shower with Jake, and we are chest to chest.
不在浴室时，杰克戴着两个助听器。没有它们他什么也听不见，所以他说话，我听。在淋浴声和回荡的声音中，我只捕捉到了一些碎片。当我们谈话时，杰克越靠越近，随着他的靠近，我慢慢地、不自觉地向后退，直到最后我被逼到一个角落的淋浴下，和杰克挤在一起，我们胸贴着胸。
Even though his mouth is only a couple of inches from my ear, I continue to catch only pieces of what he's saying-- 45 years, the heat, four shots of whiskey after the shevitz, seven, eight rubs I used to rub, the heat. I can't remember the last time I spoke to anyone so close, but Jake's so comfortable with it that it makes me comfortable, too. People just don't talk like this anymore. It makes me feel like I'm in an old photograph.
尽管他的嘴离我的耳朵只有几英寸，我仍然只能捕捉到他所说的一小部分——45年，热度，蒸完桑拿后喝四杯威士忌，七、八次搓澡，热度。我不记得上次和别人这么近距离说话是什么时候了，但杰克对此感到非常自在，这也让我感到自在。人们不再像这样交谈了。这让我觉得我置身于一张旧照片中。
The water falls down on us and it's like we're two sleep walkers bumping into each other in the summer rain of the shtetl. It all feels dreamy and long ago, and Jake's taken me there, and I'm glad I'm with him.
水洒在我们身上，就像我们是两个在小镇的夏雨中撞在一起的梦游者。一切都感觉梦幻而遥远，杰克带我去了那里，我很高兴能和他在一起。
Right here, this is life stripped of all the fat. It's the best part of being at the gym, a good sweat without any of the exercise. It's probably even the best part of prison, the showers and the fresh soap. I'd even go so far as to say that this would be the best part of hell as you step into the first blast of soothing womb-like heat.
就在这里，这就是剥去所有脂肪的生活。这是在健身房里最好的部分，不需要任何运动就能出一身好汗。这甚至可能是监狱里最好的部分，淋浴和新鲜的肥皂。我甚至会说，当你踏入第一阵令人舒缓的子宫般的热浪时，这将是地狱里最好的部分。
So we sit and we sweat. It's what we do. It's like we have an assembly line production going. We sit all hunched over with our brows knit. We stare down at the floor with a ponderous, quiet intensity. We are engaged in serious business. Sweating makes us feel productive, like we're doing good work down here, getting things accomplished.
所以我们坐着，我们出汗。这就是我们所做的。就像我们正在进行流水线生产一样。我们弓着背坐着，眉头紧锁。我们带着沉重、安静的专注盯着地板。我们在做正经事。出汗让我们感到有成效，就像我们在做有益的工作，把事情办好。
Jake's younger son, Willy, calls me over. He's giving a large, hairy man a massage with an oak leaf brush and wants me to see. Have you ever seen a real Russian-style massage, asks Willy, as the naked, 300-pound man lying on his back that he's attending to obligingly raises his legs in the air like a baby about to be diapered. Willy lifts the brush over his shoulder and brings it down between the man's legs over and over. He does this with a kind of casualness that suggests whipping a naked man in the privates is the most normal thing in the world. And I watch them completely and utterly freaked out, which is, I think, the result Willy was going for.
杰克的小儿子威利叫我过去。他正在用橡树叶刷给一个多毛的大块头男人按摩，并想让我看看。你见过真正的俄罗斯式按摩吗？威利问道，这时那个他正在照料的、光着身子躺在背上的300磅男人顺从地把腿抬在空中，像个要换尿布的婴儿。威利把刷子举过肩膀，在男人两腿之间反复刷动。他做这一切时带着一种随意的态度，这表明鞭打一个光身男人的隐私部位是世界上最正常的事情。我看着他们，感到彻底的震惊，我认为这就是威利想要的结果。
The men in the bathhouse watch the massaged one get massaged like it's TV, like they're watching an infomercial when there's nothing else better on. And then suddenly-- and by suddenly, I mean not suddenly, because everything down there happens as though submerged in cherry sauce-- they are all pitching in, and you can't tell who works there and who doesn't. They're all over some guy just for the thrill of doing the job right.
浴室里的男人看着那个被按摩的人像看电视一样，就像在没什么好节目时看电视购物节目。然后突然——我的意思是并不突然，因为下面发生的一切就像浸在樱桃酱里一样——他们全都加入进来，你分不清谁是在那儿工作的，谁不是。他们全围着某个家伙，仅仅是为了把工作做好的快感。
And then there's the buckets. Sitting in the heat, the old men take old-fashioned buckets of ice cold water and dump them over each other's heads to cool down. Seeing this is like stumbling into a long running performance of the world's oldest joke. It reminds me of how, when I was seven, my grandfather in a remnant of such old country playfulness dumped a bucket of garden hose water over my head at a family barbecue, and how I spent the rest of the afternoon all traumatized and generally spazzed out vowing never again to trust anyone over 75.
还有水桶。坐在热气里，老人们拿着老式的冰水桶，往对方头上倒来降温。看到这一幕就像跌进了一个经久不衰的世界最古老笑话的表演。它让我想起我七岁时，我的祖父在一次家庭烧烤中，带着这种老派的顽皮，把一桶花园软管的水倒在我头上，我剩下的整个下午都受到了惊吓，通常表现得很歇斯底里，发誓再也不相信任何超过75岁的人。
Jake and his sons invite me upstairs to eat with them. Dressed only in our sheets and towels, we sit around a table in the dining room off the locker room, and we eat. Eating bare-chested at home by yourself makes you feel like you've simply given up on life, but eating bare-chested in a room full of other bare-chested men makes you feel like a Greek god among other Greek gods.
杰克和他的儿子们邀请我上楼和他们一起吃饭。我们只裹着床单和毛巾，围坐在更衣室旁边的餐厅里吃饭。独自在家赤裸上身吃饭会让你觉得你已经放弃了生活，但在满是赤裸上身男人的房间里吃饭会让你觉得自己是希腊众神中的一员。
Jake pulls out a plastic container of homemade herring. I made that, he says poking his finger into the piece on my plate. We pass around bread and club soda, big silver bowls of salad-- steam bath salad it's called in the menu posted on the wall. There's also one called the garbage salad. These are the kinds of names men give to things.
杰克拿出一罐自制的鲱鱼。我做的，他一边说一边用手指戳着我盘子里的一块。我们传递着面包和苏打水，装着色拉的银色大碗——在墙上贴的菜单上叫蒸汽浴色拉。还有一个叫垃圾色拉。这些就是男人们给事物起的名字。
This is what all of life would be like if it were a world of only men. In a world of such men, a Havarti with sprouts on oat bread would be called a foot sandwich. There's simply too much work to be done and no time to invent clever names. Give me two feet and a side of garbage, they might say after a 15-hour day of raking farm soil with their fingers.
如果这是一个只有男人的世界，生活就会是这样。在这样一个男人的世界里，带芽的哈瓦蒂奶酪配燕麦面包会被称为脚趾三明治。简而言之，有太多的工作要做，没时间去发明聪明的名字。在用手指耙了15小时农田后，他们可能会说，给我两个脚趾和一份垃圾。
We watch a Clint Eastwood movie on an enormous screen. We read magazines while talking about other movies. We let our stomachs pour over what would, that we were wearing pants, be our belt buckles. It is a world governed entirely by testosterone. Oh, I'm not talking about the chest pounding, loud-mouthed testosterone that gets so much press these days. I'm talking about the other kind of maleness, the gentler, more utilitarian maleness. The unselfconsciously picking the teeth with a playing card to get out the last stringy bits of roast beef kind of maleness.
我们在巨大的屏幕上观看克林特·伊斯特伍德的电影。我们读杂志，谈论其他电影。我们任由肚子垂在裤腰带上。这是一个完全由睾酮支配的世界。哦，我说的不是今天媒体报道的那种拍胸脯、大嗓门的睾酮。我说的是另一种男性气质，那种更温和、更实用的男性气质。那种不自觉地用扑克牌剔牙以弄出烤牛肉最后一丝纤维的男性气质。
An old man passes our table on his way downstairs. How's the heat, he asks. Hot, I answer. You think this is hot? Wait till the Russians come, says Shelley. He lifts the sheet from around his waist and wipes his mouth with it.
一个老人下楼时经过我们的桌子。热度怎么样，他问。热，我回答。你觉得这叫热？等俄罗斯人来，雪莉说。他提起腰间的床单，用它擦了擦嘴。
I've been hearing this all day. Everywhere I turn people are talking about the Russians. They're masochists, says a graying fire hydrant named Seymour. Where's the enjoyment in breathing 180 degree heat, demands a water buffalo of a man named Yussy. When the Russians come, the insides of your nostrils will feel like lit match sticks. It has to do damage to the bronchial passage.
我整天都在听这个。我走到哪里，人们都在谈论俄罗斯人。他们是受虐狂，一个叫西摩的灰白消防栓说。呼吸180度的热度有什么乐趣，一个叫尤西的水牛般的男人质问。当俄罗斯人来时，你的鼻孔内部会感觉像点燃的火柴棍。这肯定会伤害支气管。
I'm told they come on Fridays, and I decide to go, too. It suddenly feels as though all the facts of my life have been leading up to the moment where I pass out in a scorching room full of naked Russians. What should I do to prepare, I ask. Go home, turn on the oven, and stick your head in, someone says.
我被告知他们周五来，我决定也去。突然感觉好像我生命中的所有事实都指向这一刻，在充满赤裸俄罗斯人的灼热房间里晕倒。我该怎么准备，我问。回家，打开烤箱，把你的头伸进去，有人说。
I imagine them descending the stairs, these Russians, single file, slapping each other on the back, rolling hot coals between their fingers, each one manning a different thermostat. They pass buckets of water down the line like they're sandbagging a dam. They throw heat like gods, like bolts of heartburn. You can't touch your own skin without leaving finger-sized welts.
我想象他们走下楼梯，这些俄罗斯人，单排，互相拍打着背，在手指间滚动热煤，每个人操作不同的恒温器。他们像加固大坝一样传递着水桶。他们像神一样投射热度，像火烧心一样的闪电。你甚至不能触摸自己的皮肤，否则就会留下手指大小的痕迹。
I imagine winning them over with my amiable taunts. It's like a refrigerator in here, I'll say. Perhaps we should build some shelves to store open jars of mayonnaise. Had I known you gentlemen came here for the tepidness and not the heat, I would have brought a cup of hot cocoa and a shawl to drape across my lap.
我想象用我友好的戏谑赢得他们。这儿简直像个冰箱，我会说。也许我们应该建些货架来存放开封的蛋黄酱罐子。如果我知道你们这些绅士来这儿是为了温和而不是热度，我会带上一杯热可可和一条披在膝盖上的披肩。
So I come back on Friday to see the Russians, and it's hotter, but only moderately so. The men sit around with the same indifference. An old man, who I'd like to think is Russian, sits in the corner brushing his teeth with his finger.
所以我周五回来见俄罗斯人，天气更热了，但只是适度热。男人们带着同样的冷漠坐着。一个老人，我愿意认为他是俄罗斯人，坐在角落里用手指刷牙。
And then something positively strange happens. As I sit there wondering if the old man in the corner will pluck a hair from his head and finish off his teeth with a good and proper flossing, out of the steam emerges the tall, naked body of the Reverend Jesse Jackson, and no one gives him a second glance.
然后发生了一件极其奇怪的事情。当我坐在那儿想那个角落里的老人是否会拔下一根头发，用正确的方法剔牙时，杰西·杰克逊牧师高大赤裸的身体从蒸汽中出现，没有人看他第二眼。
Bath people truly don't give a crap, and even if they did, it would be too hot to do anything about anyway. They treat Jackson in the same way they treat everyone, with a pleasant indifference. They watch as Agi, one of the paid masseurs, works him over in much the way they watch anyone else getting massaged, but perhaps out of respect they do not pitch in.
浴室里的人真的不在乎，即使他们想，也太热了，什么也做不了。他们像对待其他人一样对待杰克逊，带着一种愉快的冷漠。他们看着阿吉，其中一个付费按摩师，以他们看着其他人被按摩的方式对他进行按摩，但也许出于尊重，他们没有插手。
And afterwards, in the dining area, the Reverend has to wait for service like everybody else. He stands naked at the counter trying to catch the cook's eye. The cook sees him and continues to stir his massive pot of soup, and then finally, he comes over.
之后，在用餐区，牧师必须像其他人一样等待服务。他光着身子站在柜台前，试图吸引厨师的注意。厨师看到了他，继续搅拌那一大锅汤，最后他走了过来。
I'd like a cheese toast, says Jackson. Grilled cheese, answers the chef pointing to the menu. Cheese, repeats Jackson, with toast. Grilled cheese, assures the chef.
我想要一份奶酪吐司，杰克逊说。烤奶酪，厨师指着菜单回答。奶酪，杰克逊重复道，带吐司。烤奶酪，厨师保证道。
I find out afterwards that Jackson often comes to the bathhouse. In fact, I'm told, that when he got back from Bosnia, he came in for a sweat, and as he passed through the dining room, 20 odd men in their sheets and bath towels all rose up and without saying a thing, gave him a standing ovation. And then, wordlessly, they went back to their meals.
我后来发现杰克逊经常来这家浴室。事实上，有人告诉我，当他从波斯尼亚回来时，他来这儿出了一身汗，当他经过餐厅时，20多个裹着床单和浴巾的男人全都站了起来，一言不发，给了他起立鼓掌。然后，他们默默地又回去继续他们的餐点。
When I leave the bathhouse, the 90 degree heat outside feels surprisingly cool and refreshing. It's the middle of August in Chicago, and yet the streets feel air conditioned. It's like being freed from a sweat box into a less intense sweat box, and I am inured. I stroll home feeling comfortable and good.
当我离开浴室时，外面的90度高温感觉出奇地凉爽清爽。那是芝加哥的八月中旬，然而街道感觉像是开了空调。这就像从一个桑拿房被释放到一个不那么激烈的桑拿房，我适应了。我感到舒适和美好，慢慢走回家。
As I round the corner onto my street, I see the fire hydrant across from my house is open, and neighborhood kids are jumping around in the stream. Brothers carry their sisters kicking and laughing into the water. Little kids run out in their pajamas.
当我拐过街角走上我的街道时，我看到我家对面的消防栓开了，社区里的孩子们在水流中跳来跳去。兄弟们背着他们的姐妹，踢着腿笑着跑进水里。小孩子们穿着睡衣跑了出来。
At home, my girlfriend, Heather, has just put her daughter, Arizona, to bed. If we wake her, she'll probably remember it for the rest of her life, I say. And so, we wake up Arizona. Outside on the street, Heather says she's never actually seen an open fire hydrant except for in the movies. When she says this, it makes me realize the same thing.
在家里，我的女朋友海瑟刚刚把她的女儿亚利桑那哄睡着。如果我们叫醒她，她可能会记一辈子，我说。于是，我们叫醒了亚利桑那。在街道外面，海瑟说她除了在电影里，从来没见过打开的消防栓。当她这么说时，我意识到同样的事情。
Arizona rubs the sleep from her eyes and runs into the flood in her little nightgown. She jumps in beside a large woman bathing a small dog with her dress lifted to her knees. It feels like the whole city is getting cool for a while, and Arizona doesn't know where to start.
亚利桑那揉了揉睡眼，穿着她的小睡裙跑进洪水里。她在一位把连衣裙提到膝盖、正在给小狗洗澡的胖女人旁边跳了进去。感觉整个城市都在暂时降温，亚利桑那不知道从哪里开始。
Jonathan Goldstein is one of the producers of our program and the author of a funny and kind of great novel called Lenny Bruce Is Dead.
乔纳森·戈尔茨坦是我们节目的制作人之一，也是一本有趣且很棒的小说《莱尼·布鲁斯已死》的作者。
[MUSIC - "IT'S TOO DARN HOT" BY ELLA FITZGERALD]
[音乐 - 艾拉·费兹洁拉的“天太热了”]
Well, Act Three, You Can Have Your Cave and Eat There Too. So it's over 90 degrees outside. If you simply head under the earth into a massive cavern, the temperature drops to a comfortable 56 degrees. For a refreshing change to end this rather sticky and overheated edition of our program, Sarah Vowell headed into such a cave.
好了，第三幕，“你可以拥有你的洞穴并在那里吃东西”。外面气温超过90度。如果你直接进入巨大的地底洞穴，温度会降到舒适的56度。为了给这期有点粘稠和过热的节目画上一个清爽的句号，莎拉·沃威尔走进了这样一个洞穴。
I am a rube who reads guide books. That's how I learned that the Old Faithful Inn at Yellowstone National Park is the world's largest log structure, and that one may sit on its balcony and sip a gin and tonic while watching Old Faithful spout off. Another guidebook tipped me off that visitors to Theodore Roosevelt National Park in North Dakota may partake in the nearby towns Pitchfork Fondue, in which rib eye steaks are speared on the end of pitch forks and dunked in barrels of boiling oil. Crispy, theatrical meat as the sun goes down over the Badlands.
我是个读旅游指南的土包子。我就是这样了解到黄石国家公园的老忠实旅馆是世界上最大的原木建筑，人们可以坐在阳台上啜饮杜松子酒和汤力水，同时看着老忠实喷泉喷发。另一本旅游指南告诉我，北达科他州西奥多·罗斯福国家公园的游客可以参加附近小镇的“干草叉火锅”，人们把肋眼牛排插在干草叉末端，浸入沸腾的油桶中。夕阳落下恶地时，这是酥脆而充满戏剧性的肉。
In this fondness for these things, I am not alone, for I have sat on picnic tables among my countrymen, some of whom stood down the Nazis, and we smile at the landscape and at one another, the grease trickling onto our souvenir T-shirts.
在对这些事物的喜爱上，我并不孤单，因为我曾坐在我的同胞们中间的野餐桌旁，其中一些人曾打败过纳粹，我们对着风景和彼此微笑，油脂滴在我们的纪念T恤上。
Paging through a guidebook entry on New Mexico's Carlsbad Caverns National Park, the words Underground Lunchroom caught my eye. The Lunchroom is smack dab in the middle of the caverns, 750 feet underground. The guidebook warned, to modern eyes this strange installation seems absurd, but moves to close it down have been stymied by its place in popular affections. As I would come to find out, it is a restaurant so oddly placed that it requires an act of Congress repeated every year to keep it going.
翻阅旅游指南中关于新墨西哥州卡尔斯巴德洞穴国家公园的条目时，“地下午餐室”几个字吸引了我的注意。午餐室就在洞穴的中间，地下750英尺处。指南警告说：“在现代人眼中，这个奇怪的装置似乎很荒谬，但关闭它的行动因它在大众心中的地位而受阻。”正如我后来发现的那样，这是一个位置如此古怪的餐厅，以至于每年都需要国会的一项法案来维持它的运作。
$13.73. Would you like any barbecue or sweet and sour sauce for your chicken?
13.73美元。您的鸡肉需要烧烤酱还是酸甜酱？
Um, barbecue please.
嗯，烧烤酱，谢谢。
If the geological marvels of Carlsbad Caverns came into being in the time before history, the Underground Lunchroom represents the time before arugula. First established in 1926, the Lunchroom was renovated in the 1970s and it shows.
如果卡尔斯巴德洞穴的地质奇观产生于历史之前，地下午餐室则代表了芝麻菜之前的时代。午餐室始建于1926年，在1970年代进行了翻新，这一点显而易见。
The food and souvenir stations are housed in sandy, brown booths that remind me of the drive-thru bank architecture of my childhood. The food-- box lunches of cold chicken or ham sandwiches, wedges of pie in plastic wedge-shaped containers-- is the sort of fare my grade school washed down with Shasta cola on the Freedom Train field trip in '76. Not long after the bicentennial, middle Americans started eating better and dressing better and calling nature the environment, but the Underground Lunchroom is a throwback to our unpretentious if unenlightened past.
食品和纪念品站被安置在沙褐色的摊位里，让我想起了童年时期的免下车银行建筑。食物——盒装冷鸡肉或火腿三明治，塑料楔形容器里的馅饼——是我小学在76年“自由列车”实地考察时用沙士汽水送服的那种餐食。建国两百周年后不久，美国中西部地区的人们开始吃得更好、穿得更好，并把大自然称为环境，但地下午餐室是对我们不假修饰、如果说未开化的过去的怀旧。
The National Park Service wanted to get rid of it. In 1991, they began an environmental assessment of the Lunchroom. Money was spent, scientists conferred, it took two years, and sadly for them, they were unable to find any conclusive evidence that food particles, Freon gas in the refrigerators, or the use of microwave ovens were harming the ecosystem and climate of the cave. In fact, all sorts of things pose a bigger ecological threat to the cave than the Lunchroom does, like the existence of lights, of an elevator, of actual bacteria carrying tourists with their lint-covered clothing.
国家公园管理局想除掉它。1991年，他们开始对午餐室进行环境评估。花了钱，科学家们进行了磋商，花了两年时间，遗憾的是，对于他们来说，他们无法找到任何确凿的证据表明食物颗粒、冰箱里的氟利昂气体或微波炉的使用正在损害洞穴的生态系统和气候。事实上，各种事物都比午餐室对洞穴构成更大的生态威胁，比如灯光、电梯、以及实际上携带着细菌、衣服上沾满棉絮的游客。
In the end, the reason the Park Service wants to close the Lunchroom doesn't have to do with science. It has to do with aesthetics. In the years since the Lunchroom was built, we as a people have gone through a grand tectonic shift in the way we think about National Parks.
最后，公园管理局想要关闭午餐室的原因与科学无关。这与美学有关。自从午餐室建成以来的这些年里，作为民族，我们在看待国家公园的方式上经历了一场巨大的构造转变。
Basically, we don't believe in putting crap in the middle of nature anymore. And we believe in taking out as much of the old crap as we can. This was codified in a 1991 Park Service policy called the Vail Agenda, which clearly states, "The National Park Service should use existing authority to remove wherever possible unnecessary facilities."
基本上，我们不再相信在大自然中间放置垃圾了。我们相信尽可能多地清除旧垃圾。这在1991年公园管理局一项名为“韦尔议程”的政策中被编纂，明确指出：“国家公园管理局应利用现有权力，尽可能移除不必要的设施。”
Well, we're standing at the big room junction. This is where the natural entrance--
好了，我们站在大厅交汇处。这就是自然入口——
It's the aesthetics of all this that Ed Green talks about when we walk through the cavern and he makes the case for the removal of the Lunchroom. Green is in charge of visitor services at Carlsbad Caverns National Park. He contributed to that environmental study. And he spends so much time underground amidst the marvels of the cavern that he has a separate name for the world that you and I inhabit. He calls that world the surface world.
当我们走过洞穴，埃德·格林为移除午餐室辩护时，他谈论的就是这一切的美学。格林负责卡尔斯巴德洞穴国家公园的游客服务。他为那项环境研究做出了贡献。他在地下的奇观中花费了如此多的时间，以至于他对你我居住的世界有一个单独的称呼。他称那个世界为“地表世界”。
It's hard to describe this for someone who can't see it, because there's nothing in the surface world experience that prepares people to see something like this. It just is unlike anything else on earth.
很难向看不到它的人描述这一点，因为地表世界的经历中没有什么能让人准备好看到这样的东西。它就是与地球上的任何其他东西都不同。
There will be times that I will intentionally-- if I'm having a rough day or something is getting under my skin a little bit, I'll just intentionally come down in the cave and find a place just to sit and kind of soak this up. This resource and this kind of beauty keeps me humble and keeps me on the right path to do the things that I need to be doing here.
会有一些时候，我会故意——如果我度过了艰难的一天或者有什么事情让我感到困扰，我会故意来到洞穴，找个地方坐下来，沉浸其中。这种资源和这种美丽让我保持谦卑，让我保持在正确的道路上，去做我在这里需要做的事情。
Nobody created Carlsbad Caverns so that they could have lunch 750 feet underground. If you walk down through the natural entrance, what you are experiencing is this natural creation, and then as you exit out of that area and you walk into this area, there's a stark contrast. You know, that's the first thing you see when you walk out. You're coming to one of the world's great natural attractions, one of the greatest attractions in all creation, and what do you see? Something not unlike maybe a mall somewhere.
没有人创造卡尔斯巴德洞穴是为了能在地下750英尺处吃午饭。如果你从自然入口走下来，你所经历的是这种自然创造，然后当你从那个区域离开并走进这个区域时，有一种强烈的对比。你知道，那是你走出来时看到的第一件事。你来到的是世界上最伟大的自然景点之一，所有创造中最伟大的景点之一，而你看到了什么？某种可能像某个购物中心的东西。
If the Park Service reasoning for removing the Underground Lunchroom is essentially an aesthetic argument, the main reason to save the Lunchroom is equally aesthetic. Namely, it's cool to eat lunch in a cave. You can also mail a postcard from the Lunchroom and stamp it, mailed 750 feet underground. It's entertaining to mail a postcard in a cave. The Lunchroom even has a bank of pay phones. Why would you need to make a telephone call from the cave? Well, you wouldn't need to. You might do it because it's fun, and you're on vacation, and you're at a place with the word park in its name.
如果公园管理局移除地下午餐室的理由本质上是一个美学论点，那么保留午餐室的主要理由同样是美学的。即，在洞穴里吃午饭很酷。你还可以从午餐室寄出一张明信片并盖上邮戳，在地下750英尺处寄出。在洞穴里寄明信片很有趣。午餐室甚至有一排公用电话。为什么你需要从洞穴里打个电话？嗯，你不需要。你可能会这么做，因为这很有趣，你正在度假，而且你所在的地方名字里带有“公园”这个词。
The Carlsbad business community partly depends on vacationers for their livelihood. So when the National Park Service announced their plans to remove the Underground Lunchroom, the Carlsbad Chamber of Commerce opposed them. Gary Perkowski is the mayor of Carlsbad. Like a lot of locals, he also worked in the Underground Lunchroom as a teenager. He was one of the people from Carlsbad who argued the Lunchroom's merits before one of New Mexico's congressman, Representative Joe Skeen.
卡尔斯巴德商界在一定程度上依赖度假者来维持生计。因此，当国家公园管理局宣布他们移除地下午餐室的计划时，卡尔斯巴德商会反对他们。加里·佩尔科夫斯基是卡尔斯巴德市长。和许多当地人一样，他青少年时期也在地下午餐室工作过。他是卡尔斯巴德 argued（争辩）午餐室优点的人之一，在他的一位新墨西哥州国会议员、众议员乔·斯基恩面前。
Well, I think Representative Skeen has always been on our side, and he works very closely with the leaders of Carlsbad on numerous projects. And we just went to Washington, explained our position, and what we thought, and he agreed with us.
嗯，我认为斯基恩众议员一直站在我们这边，他与卡尔斯巴德的领导人在众多项目上合作非常紧密。我们只是去了华盛顿，解释了我们的立场和我们的想法，他同意了我们的看法。
That's it?
就这些？
That's basically it. He agreed with our position and did everything he could to make sure that that was implemented.
基本上就是这样。他同意了我们的立场，并尽他所能确保其得到实施。
I'll say. I read to you now from the following legislation prepared by Representative Skeen's committee. "According to HR 2217, the Department of the Interior and related agencies appropriations act for fiscal year 2002, section 307, none of the funds made available by this act may be obligated or expended by the National Park Service to enter into or implement a concession contract which permits or requires the removal of the Underground Lunchroom at the Carlsbad Caverns National Park."
我得说。我现在为你朗读众议员斯基恩委员会准备的以下立法。“根据HR 2217，2002财政年度内政部及相关机构拨款法案，第307节，本法案提供的任何资金均不得被国家公园管理局用于签订或执行一项允许或要求移除卡尔斯巴德洞穴国家公园地下午餐室的特许合同。”
That is the same language that has appeared in every appropriations bill since 1994, and what it means is that the National Park Service is barred from using federal funds to close down the Underground Lunchroom. Calls to Representative Skeen's office for comment were not returned.
那正是自1994年以来出现在每一项拨款法案中的同样措辞，它的意思是国家公园管理局被禁止使用联邦资金来关闭地下午餐室。给众议员斯基恩办公室打去的置评请求未获回复。
The National Park Service is obeying the will of Congress, but you don't get the feeling they're all that happy about it. If the Park Service were a person, the Underground Lunchroom would be one of the dumb mistakes it made as a kid. It's like Congress is telling it that it not only cannot remove the tattoo it got one drunken night in the '20s, it has to invite 300,000 people a year to look at it. And that's how a lot of employees think about it, too, as a youthful gaffe.
国家公园管理局正在服从国会的意志，但你感觉他们对此并不怎么高兴。如果公园管理局是一个人，地下午餐室将是它小时候犯的一个愚蠢错误。这就像国会告诉它，不仅不能移除它在20年代某个醉酒夜晚纹下的纹身，还必须邀请每年30万人在那儿看它。而这就是很多员工对它的看法，一个年少时的失礼。
Cave specialist, Ron Kerbo, who was one of the authors of the study calling for the Lunchroom's abolition, remembers going there when he was little.
洞穴专家罗恩·克博是呼吁废除午餐室的研究报告的作者之一，他记得小时候去过那里。
Like any eight year old, I thought it was pretty interesting to be able to eat in the cave, and I particularly remember the pickles. They used to have these shelves with these little paper cup things, little small paper cups with pickles in them, and you could eat as many of those as you wanted. So I was always very fond of eating the pickles in the Underground Lunchroom.
像任何八岁的孩子一样，我觉得能在那儿吃东西非常有趣，我特别记得那些酸黄瓜。他们曾经有带这些小纸杯的架子，装有酸黄瓜的小纸杯，你可以随心所欲地吃多少都行。所以我一直非常喜欢在地下午餐室吃酸黄瓜。
Still, he says, there's no reason for the Lunchroom today. Food is available to tourists in a restaurant that's just 57 seconds away by elevator. And for all the visitors who enter the cavern through the elevator, the Lunchroom is the first and the last thing that they see.
尽管如此，他说，今天没有理由再留着午餐室。游客在距离电梯仅57秒路程的餐厅里就能吃到食物。对于所有通过电梯进入洞穴的游客来说，午餐室是他们看到的第一样和最后一样东西。
In that environment, it seems to me, eating in the Lunchroom mars the visitors' experience in the cave.
在我看来，在那种环境下，在午餐室用餐损害了游客在洞穴中的体验。
And when you were eight years old, did you feel marred?
那你八岁的时候，觉得受损了吗？
Well, yes, as a child, I ate in there, and I enjoyed it, and I did remember it, but I have moved on. And the great thing that the National Parks teach us is that, if we are attuned to these natural processes, then we can move on. If your only memory of Carlsbad Cavern is eating in the Lunchroom, then you have missed the essence of the experience.
嗯，是的，作为一个孩子，我在那儿吃过，我很享受，我也记得，但我已经走出来了。国家公园教给我们最棒的事情是，如果我们顺应这些自然过程，我们就能走出来。如果关于卡尔斯巴德洞穴你唯一的记忆就是在这儿吃午饭，那么你就错过了这次体验的精髓。
Everything he's saying is true, but when I got off the phone with him, I was really frustrated because my only possible counter argument is that the Underground Lunchroom is really neat. And what's the dignity in that? Since the Lunchroom does no significant harm to the cavern's ecology, I'd like to believe that this is one of those lucky places where we don't have to choose between doing the right thing and enjoying a goof.
他说的一切都是真的，但当我挂断电话时，我真的很沮丧，因为我唯一可能的反驳理由是，地下午餐室真的很酷。而那有什么尊严可言呢？既然午餐室对洞穴的生态没有重大危害，我宁愿相信这是一个我们不必在做正确的事和享受乐趣之间做出选择的幸运地方。
I spent a couple hours walking down through the caverns, and this is what I saw. I saw 14 football fields of treasures, things with names like Witch's Finger, Totem Pole, Mirror Lake, formations described as popcorn and soda straws in places called the Boneyard or the Hall of Giants. I don't know how to describe the magnificence of Carlsbad Caverns without making it sound like a cartoon or a drug trip or a cartoon of a drug trip. The only thing I can say is that it is one of those dear places that make you love the world.
我花了几小时走过洞穴，这就是我所看到的。我看到了14个足球场大小的宝藏，名字像“女巫的手指”、“图腾柱”、“镜湖”的东西，地貌被描述为“爆米花”和“苏打吸管”，在被称为“骸骨场”或“巨人厅”的地方。我不知道该如何描述卡尔斯巴德洞穴的壮丽，而不让它听起来像卡通片或毒品之旅，或者卡通版的毒品之旅。我唯一能说的是，它是那些让你爱上这个世界的亲爱之地之一。
So when I came to the end of the last trail, I wasn't quite ready to say goodbye to the cave. I felt all dreamy, and I didn't want the feeling to end. I look up at the ceiling of the Lunchroom, which is, of course, the ceiling of the cave.
所以当我走到最后一条小径的尽头时，我还没准备好和洞穴说再见。我感到很梦幻，不想那种感觉结束。我抬头看着午餐室的天花板，当然，也就是洞穴的天花板。
It looks so lunar I can't help but think of a certain astronaut. In 1971, Apollo 14's Alan Shepard hit golf balls on the moon. Gearing up to face the profundity of the universe, this man brought sporting goods with him into space. Who can blame him? That's what we Americans do when we find a place that's really special. We go there and act exactly like ourselves, and we are a nation of fun-loving dopes.
它看起来如此像月球，我不禁想到一位特定的宇航员。1971年，阿波罗14号的艾伦·谢泼德在月球上打高尔夫球。在准备面对宇宙深邃之时，这个人把体育用品带进了太空。谁能怪他呢？这就是我们美国人在找到一个真正特别的地方时会做的事。我们去那儿，表现得和我们一模一样，我们是一个爱玩的笨蛋民族。
I sleepwalk to a picnic table in the Underground Lunchroom. When I first read about the Lunchroom in the guidebook, I'd never suspected it could feel so contemplative. Then I rip open a bag of barbecue potato chips and listen to the sound of my own teeth crunching. It is possible in the Lunchroom to chew and ponder at the same time.
我梦游到地下午餐室的一张野餐桌前。当我第一次在旅游指南中读到午餐室时，我从未想到它能让人如此沉思。然后我撕开一袋烧烤味薯片，听着我自己的牙齿嘎吱作响的声音。在午餐室里一边咀嚼一边思考是有可能的。
Sarah Vowell is the author of the book, Take the Cannoli.
莎拉·沃威尔是《带上甜筒》一书的作者。
Well, our program was produced today by Wendy Dorr and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jonathan Goldstein, and Starlee Kine. Senior producer Julie Snyder. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Paul McCarthy. Music help from Mr. John Connors. Hi, John.
好了，我们今天的节目由温蒂·多尔和我本人与亚历克斯·布隆伯格、乔纳森·戈尔茨坦和斯塔莉·基恩共同制作。资深制作人朱莉·斯奈德。托德·巴赫曼和保罗·麦卡锡提供了制作帮助。约翰·康纳斯先生提供了音乐帮助。嗨，约翰。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who recently had a bucket fall on his head and woke up saying--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他最近头上掉下一个水桶，醒来后说——
45 years, the heat, four shots of whiskey after the shevitz, seven, eight rubs I used to rub--
45年，热度，蒸完桑拿后喝四杯威士忌，七、八次搓澡……
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台，PRI。